et merci d'être là véronique mais alors
verdict actuellement en tournée en
france huet et fait une énorme tournée
et ça c'était une exclusivité ce que tu
nous a offert ce soir
alors tu as travaillé de nouvelle
boillat claramunt yannick je kiffe je
peux pas me faire un peu de la grenade
la com ça va et toi qu'est ce que tu
regarde jamais vu une femme qui se bat
le faire on connaît les bons combien il
ya angel aussi tu as we angèle que
j'adore angèle parce que je trouve qu'il
manque c'est une jeune artiste plein de
talent est tellement intelligente
c'est vraiment une jeune fille que
j'aime beaucoup et dans le spectacle
d'ailleurs on fire nakamura
et puis en guise et des voix comme et
les klaus a fait quoi angèle tout il
faut peut-être nous d'oublier
or y croire il faudra tout donner
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
véronic dicaire qui est un spectacle
merci véronique travail touchaient
demandé de faire plein de trucs